dieser asteroid enthält so viel gold
dass er uns alle zu milliardären machen
würde psyche 16 so der name enthält
unter umständen gold im wert von 625
millionen euro
das wäre eine unfassbar große summe für
jeden menschen auf der erde allerdings
gibt es einen kleinen haken klicks und
science fiction er gibt es täglich
spannende science videos aber nicht den
kanal
denn nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen im netz kursieren
für psyche 16 wirklich unfassbare
schätzungen was sein goldgehalt angeht
gold im wert von 625 millionen euro das
wären für jeden menschen auf der erde
unglaubliche 83 milliarden euro gold
wert wahnsinn auf zu psyche 16 würde ich
mal sagen und tatsächlich ist die nasa
auf dem weg zur psyche 16
beziehungsweise hat den start einer
mission geplant diese absurd ist nämlich
so oder so unglaublich spannend sein
extrem hoher metallgehalt lässt
fachleute nämlich vermuten dass er mal
der kern eines etwa maß großen planeten
war im gegensatz zu den meisten anderen
asteroiden hat er nämlich einen
metallkern und das ist extrem selten und
des lässt forschungsteams vermuten das
ist der kern eben eines zerstörten
planeten es im laufe der milliarden
jahre hat er seine hülle eingebüßt und
nur noch der kern existiert als asteroid
der rest könnte als zahlreiche weitere
asteroiden immer so ihren gürtel
zwischen mars und jupiter die sonne
umkreisen mesto ihnen würde
nimmt man ja an dass sich dort wegen der
schwerkraft des jupiters nie ein planet
bilden konnte und deshalb nur als
soliden entstanden sind psyche wäre aber
der hinweis auf einen planeten die
erkenntnisse einer nasa mission dürften
also hoch spannend sein
die mission psyche wird im august 2000
22 staaten 2023 würde es einen swing by
manöver mars geben und 2026 wird die
sonde psyche erreichen
die sonde wird das magnetfeld vom psyche
untersuchen und zum ersten mal ein neues
kommunikationssystem der nasa testen
deep space optical communications
arbeitet mit leser und übermittelt die
daten zehnmal schneller als bisherige
systeme neben der vermessung des
magnetfeldes werden auch hochauflösende
fotos übermittelt um zu erkennen was
metall und was gestein auf dem
asteroiden ist danach wissen wir mehr
über psyche und vor allem unser
sonnensystem gab es noch einen planeten
von milliarden jahren und ist er im
asteroidengürtel in form von asteroiden
enthalten
und dann werden wir auch wissen ob der
astra in gold enthält und wie viel oder
ob er nur aus eisen und nickel besteht
aber selbst wenn er aus gold bestehen
würde
und wenn wir dieses gold mit astrid
mining abbauen und zur erde bringen
würden wären die folgen etwas
enttäuschend denn der wert von gold
beruht auf seiner seltenheit hätte also
jeder mensch gold im heutigen wert von
83 milliarden euro wäre es fast nichts
mehr wert der wert würde dann durch den
wert ersetzt werden der durch die kosten
des abbaus entstehen würde aber das wäre
dann wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger als
83 milliarden euro schade
es spielt also gar keine rolle ob der
kehr nun aus gold oder eisen und nickel
besteht aber es gibt hoch spannende
nachrichten aus der vergangenheit am 20
juli berichten wir zwölf stunden lang
live von der mondlandung vor 50 jahren
wir begleiten die mondlandung 50 jahre
später sekundengenau mit all dem wissen
dass wir heute haben mit dabei sind
astronauten gerhard thiele und reinhold
ewald und zahlreiche wissenschafts
youtuber wie astro comics tv raumzeit
lockt der zukunft hacking lab der
medizinstudent doktor watson neugier
zone
und wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt dann
klickt hier und merkt euch den steam
forum 21 uhr am samstag geht es los also
bis dann bleib dran